[Applause]
sally turned into sports now the raiders
were back at home after two weeks on the
road the silver and black are entering
must
win territory as the nfl playoff picture
begins to take shape
john treach is here now with our
highlights john that's right the raiders
were the star of last week's reality
series nfl team scared straight
after they barely escaped with a victory
against the jets but
none of the focus and urgency matters
when the indianapolis colts can do
whatever they want on offense
the colts making their maiden voyage to
las vegas for business purposes
raiders down 10 nothing in a dreadful
first quarter but come alive derek carr
to
foster moreau and moreau on the go can't
be stopped
47-yard touchdown his first of the
season
second quarter sound the aguilar alarm
car to nelson agalor for the touchdown
las vegas seizes the lead
but in the hospitality capital of the
world t-y hilton has a say phillip
rivers
goes long form to the abbreviation t-y
20-14 the scored half second half
defense and confidence leaks for the
raiders jonathan taylor
running like he's back at the university
of wisconsin 62-yard touchdown
colts ran for a 212 yards and threw for
another 244
raider nation desperation worked last
week but the jets are not on the
schedule again
interception kari willis 53-yard
touchdown hill turn out the lights when
he leaves 44-27
raiders fall to seven and six and now
las vegas is in
absolute desperation mode as they
basically can't lose again and they fall
to two and four at home too so that's
where we find kevin martin at
allegiant stadium kevin
well john the raiders are fighting for
their playoff lives coming into today's
matchup with the colts
on the outside of the playoff picture
looking in so you would assume that a
team full of desperation and a sense of
urgency would take the field today
but we saw anything about that a dismal
showing defensively paired with
a lackluster showing offensively which
led to that 44 to 27 loss at the hands
of the indianapolis colts
yeah it breaks your heart you know you
lose a game like that breaks your heart
you know when you when you need a win uh
against a team you're battling with for
a playoff spot
and you don't get it it really rips your
heart out so
it is what it is you can't you can't get
it back
but just like this game
you know typically unless it's the last
week of the season and that's it
uh you have to play another one and in
our case we have another one on thursday
and so i i need to go i need to get home
and start preparing for that game it's
that's my job it's what i have to do
the raiders have now lost three of their
last four but as you just heard
quarterback derek carr say they
absolutely have to get this one put
behind them
not only because of the quick turnaround
as they host the chargers on thursday
but they just have three games remaining
on their schedule and it appears as
everything is shaking out
that all three of these games are must
wins if they want to give any chance
at the postseason reporting live at
allegion stadium kevin martin 8 sports
now